so you just said that your dad stopped
taking your calls why do you stop taking
your calls
because
i took matters and by that point i took
matters into my own hands
prince harry revealing all was not well
during the royal exit
i think everyone needs to have some
compassion for them in that situation
right there is a level of control by
fear
that has existed for generations during
harry and meghan markle's exclusive
interview with oprah winfrey sunday
night
the duke of sussex opened up about their
ongoing friction with the royal family
you wanted freedom from from that life
you wanted freedom to make your own
money
we didn't want to give up or we didn't
want to turn our backs on these the
associations and the people that we
that we've been supporting i had three
conversations with my grandmother
and two conversations with my father um
before he stopped taking my calls
and then said can you put this all in
writing what your plan is
but when prince charles first learned of
their plan to step away from royal
duties
harry said his dad's reaction sent a
clear message
so you just said that your dad stopped
taking your calls why do you stop taking
your calls
because
i took matters and by that point i took
matters into my own hands it was like i
need to do this for my family
this is not a surprise to anybody it's
really sad that it's got to this point
but i've got to do something for my own
mental health my wife's
um and for archie's as well because i
could see where this was headed
this was harry and megan's first
sit-down interview together
since before they married in 2018 and
e.t has learned the broadcast arrived
during a
tense moment for the prince's family
with harry's grandfather prince philip
having been hospitalized since february
16th
a source revealed that prince harry has
been in touch with his family since
prince philip became ill
and had been advised of the grave nature
of his condition
what this story sends out is a very
clear message that essentially
this this is a war between the palace
and the sussexes
on top of that the interview follows an
article from the times that claimed
megan bullied her aides at kensington
palace
in response to the report harry and
megan said in statement
it's no coincidence that distorted
several-year-old accusations aimed at
undermining the duchess
are being briefed to the british media
shortly before she and the duke are due
to speak openly
and honestly about their experience of
recent years
i am told that while buckingham palace
has denied having anything to do
with the times splash over this email
alleging that megan bullied two members
of staff out
they are much more concerned with the
more serious matter which is
the the health of the duke of edinburgh
who is seriously ill
in hospital and there are calls by some
royal commentators and experts who
believe that this interview
and should be rescheduled and aired at a
less sensitive time for the royal family
and there are even some reports
circulating online that prince harry is
being asked to come home
to see his grandfather
you